you're going to die two weeks after you  die most people have forgotten about you  six months after you die no one will  talk about you if they're not caring  enough then then it certainly doesn't  matter what they think about your life  now if that's the most significant event  that's going to happen in your life  which is that you stop living how much  credibility or weight should we give to  other people's opinions on what we  should do with our lives in my opinion  very little most the times it's just  worth ignoring because they're trying to  live their own life and they're  projecting their own beliefs and  experiences on you and you've spent all  this time trying to improve your own  view of reality through the beliefs that  you've shed and shifted that they have  not and so what they believe to be true  is what they're casting on to you and if  you don't like the life they have and I  don't think it's worth listening to